how many other carbons it's the latest
must wear item of school
uniform scotland is reacting to the
science
from monday these secondary school
pupils in edinburgh will have to mask up
in corridors and communal areas we know
it's not easy none of what we're all
having to live with right now
generally or in schools is easy but it
is all about trying to minimize the
risks of transmission
but where scotland has led england has
yet to follow
why do you think first minister you are
right and the uk government
is wrong on some things we've taken a
slightly different approach
sometimes that's only been for a period
of time and
you know the government that has taken a
decision first has
you know been followed at some stage by
other governments we'll see if that
turns out to be the case on face
coverings in schools
and you know i'm not going to stand here
and say i'm right and somebody else is
wrong we're all making really tough
judgments here doesn't matter the pm was
wearing his own protective equipment
today
but it won't shield him from criticism
he's moving too slow
on the issue of of whether or not to
wear masks in some context
you know we'll look at the uh the the
changing medical evidence as we as we go
on
if we need to change the advice and of
course we will not all his back benches
are convinced
one tweeted no boris johnson this is
utterly wrong masks should be banned in
schools
the country should be getting back to
normal not pandering
to this scientifically illiterate guff
the scientists
unsurprisingly disagree decisions in the
schools
are something that should be made by the
local authorities
in conjunction with the teachers and the
parents
in each area because what you need to be
very aware of is
what is the transmission status what is
actually going on in your community
back in scotland it's not a local
solution they're looking for
but a national one i think if different
parts of the country do different things
then people have almost an excuse well
why am i doing it they're not doing it
so yeah particularly when you're on one
island i get it
different nations different priorities
but i i would like to see a more
consistent message
what boris johnson's government had
ruled out they are now considering
but mines will need to be made up most
of england schools return
in just seven days time joe pike sky
news